[Music]
good day
we can grow giant models
four foot in a month
the
45 inches
these models would taste exactly the
same as a normal model
nice and tender and lush some of them
look a bit tough but once you cut into
them they cut like butter
my name is philip valz i live in tanari
whales and i grow giant vegetables
[Music]
i've been growing giant vegetables now
for the last 30 years
i come from a very large family my
mother had 17 children
13 of us survived and i think you know
that was something you know big
vegetables feed big families
you know i'm up here every morning every
night every single day of the week
there's a lot of love and keg goes into
it
sometimes i do a bit of talking to them
as well
to encourage them to grow which is a bit
of you know a bit of fun you know i
think he's just about finished growing
there now i've got to be very careful
the wife is not about when i start
talking to my vegetables but it's all
good fun
i broke the world record for the
heaviest cucumber about 25 years ago it
weighed 18 and a half pound and it was
just incredible the way it grew
you know when i started if we had
tomorrow
20 30 pound in weight you had a big
model now we're up over 100 pounding
weight
a normal cabbage would be
two pounding weights
while we are growing them 120 pounds
you know you can feed
120 130 140 people off one cabbage
this is why i supply the local pub
and they use them up for sunday lunch
i've developed my own strain more or
less now
i select my own seed every year
the biggest and the best seed and it
just seems to be improving
which is incredible
i grow organically i think if i can do
it anybody can do it
and it's a big thrill every day
the wife say what am i doing up the lot
month every day
and when she comes up she realized
if you plucked people from all across
the country and said we have a farm the
image that they have of who's that
farmer
would not be kristin leach
[Music]
my name is kristen leach and i'm a
farmer in winters california and i grow
predominantly korean and east asian
herbs and vegetables
[Music]
i was born in tegu korea
i was adopted as an infant i grew up on
long island in new york
the regional cuisine of long island is
pizza and bagels so that's what i was
just sort of raised on
i just had never really explored korean
heritage but i did get curious about the
food
oh wait this is a really good
little one
i worked on organic farms when i was a
teenager
and so i just thought like oh i know how
to grow plants maybe i should grow some
of these plants from korea just to
better understand this place where i'm
from
[Music]
i
went back to korea for the first time
since i left
i spent just like three weeks traveling
around and was learning from all of
these farmers and visiting different
farms
it felt like a pretty profound way to
actually engage with identity because it
answered for me a sense of what place i
could find within like a bigger story of
korean history
[Music]
i practice a style of farming that's
referred to as natural farming in korea
and japan
everything on the farm is grown
organically
and essentially it's the way just like
peasant subsistence farmers farm
some of the heritage crops that we focus
on here are the korean sesame leaf
the flavor is kind of licoricey
and minty
chame korean melon
is like somewhere between like a
cucumber and melon in flavor it's really
really crunchy
chili peppers a really beloved staple
and japanese eggplant just a small
baseball sized eggplant it's super dense
and really creamy
three times a week i'll usually head to
the bay to make a delivery
namu gagi is a restaurant in the mission
district in san francisco
all of the produce goes directly to
their restaurant
and their chefs and cooks figure out how
to kind of design a menu around it
my name is dennis lee i'm the chef and
owner of namukaji san francisco
[Music]
right now we're doing a really nice
simple grilled eggplant dish with a
really heavy dusting of minced perilla
we're doing a nice melon salad right now
with watermelon and korean melon we have
a chili oil that we serve with our ramen
that has korean chilies from the farm
it's a restaurant that's operated by
korean americans so you see that in what
we do
the way that our relationship works with
kristin is totally unique because it's
tied to who she is
to be able to support an asian woman and
co-create a platform to express
ourselves and share our story with
people
that's pretty special
the food that dennis is making allows
itself to just be really original and it
doesn't
feel like it's trying to just reproduce
a mold of what is korean or what is
asian american
i'm learning about like my lineage i'm
trying to figure out a sense of
belonging
the experience of adoption is so
complicated i feel really grateful to
have farming be the way that i interact
with my culture
[Music]
conita was a food desert
but i wanted to do something about it
we begin to grow
and we begin to put our hearts and hands
together and canada is no longer food
desert pinita is a food oasis
[Music]
i'm reverend richard arjuna founder
of conita family life center
kenita is a rural area in the eastern
part of north carolina population of
about 300 people
a food doesn't really mean that the
residents here do not have access to
fresh locally affordable grown foods we
buy most of our food from discount
stores which are high in sodium calories
very low nutritional values
people had these early stages of chronic
disease diabetes high blood pressure
heart attacks strokes
and even mental illness because of the
stress and some pain
people dying in their 30s and 40s we
would be having two to three funerals a
month and really devastating families
[Music]
i was really feeling overwhelmed and
feeling hopeless because i couldn't stop
this chronic disease
i pulled inside the road and really
started praying
wanting to know what could i do
and i had this epiphany of open your
eyes look around
and all over my eyes and all i saw was
fields
[Music]
so we started our first small garden
and now we're up to 21 acres of farmland
we have about eight people that are
parents and grandparents of our youth
that work here every day we have 40
students during the summer
that use this farm for their reading
writing math and science and for
food presently on our farm we have
blueberries tomatoes we have collards we
have squash we have zucchini
we end up averaging 100 pounds of food
per week out of the garden
food that we grow has had a tangible
impact upon our community
we are able to put food on people tables
hello every best of us all right
our community is spending four thousand
dollars less a month on prescription
pills because of the food
the deaths have slowed down we're not
having as many funerals i feel like we
are making a difference
i love this community here because
we're united around
saving lives together
south of mexico city is xochimilco known
for its famous floating farms or as the
locals call them chinampas
thanks lucio you got it
with the help of this farmer and this
chef
this man is fighting to keep some of
mexico's oldest farms alive
meet lucio he's one of the co-founders
of yokon a non-profit aimed at
preserving the chinampas
the chinampas are these artificial
islands
built even before the aztecs so for us
yolkan is
so important to to preserve this culture
and this space
the chinampas have some of the most
fertile land in all of mexico and
because of that some of the best produce
in the country is grown there
beneficial
today
[Music]
this is no way he's one of the farmers
that works in xochimilco and still uses
the ancient chinampa technique
[Music]
queso
[Music]
because the farmers lack the money to
hire workers they often leave the
chinampas to find better paying jobs in
the city
lucio knew that the only way to keep the
farmers in sochi milco was to get the
chinampas fresh produce into restaurants
all throughout mexico city
enter jorge vallejo
i'm the chef and the owner of the
restaurant quinton here in mexico city
jorge is considered one of mexico's top
chefs and his restaurant quintanilla is
rated number six in latin america's 50
best restaurants this guy is the real
deal
i really wanted to be part of yolkand
because you have to be aware about where
the ingredients you work with come from
who grows them if they are organic or
they are at least as natural as possible
it's almost impossible to have as fresh
as they have because everything has been
taken from the soil
hours no more than a day
so i think it's very important to not
only work with the farmers but also let
them be part of the story jorge along
with other mexican chefs worked with
yokon to buy the produce from the
chinapa farmers and include them into
their dishes we have turkey with
different vegetables from the chinampas
with different leaves that come from the
shin up as well
youkan has gone on to partner with 50
more of mexico's chefs bringing work
back to the farmers and providing hope
for the future of the chinampas
we believe that farmers are the
caretakers of the land and also of our
of our health so for us the chinampa is
this symbol of mexican agriculture we
hope that people will have a glimpse of
what sochi milko it used to be more than
800 years ago
[Music]
you